hi I'm Gwendolyn woods
I'm Fifi Clanton welcome to the Crab
Shack my father's from the Chesapeake
Bay area and so every time you go down
and visit home he would come back up to
New York with a bushel of crabs
family would all get together and spend
the whole day cracking blue crab DC area
is more beer
Oh Bay and Philly they steam it and then
they douse it with garlic butter and
then just sprinkle obeyed so our take on
crabs is we basically cook the crabs in
beer and then drizzle it with the garlic
butter and then we sprinkle it with obey
so it's a combination but we put our own
flavor to it so now it's Brooklyn so
this is our Alaskan snow crab ladder you
know this is something that takes a
little bit of time most people save this
big guy for last that's the claw I'll
get to that this is by far my favorite
part the crab this is called the Maris
and to me it's the sweetest it's the
most fun it's the most plump oh we got
to eat that part first and you break off
at the knuckles okay and the knuckles
here again and you pull out that
cartilage and then you put your
fingertips in the center you feel the
middle and you don't crack all the way
because you don't want to break it and
then you want to be able to just pull
that out like that when this happens you
said you don't want to let a little
piece of meat go to waste because you
just don't want to do that and just
little guy a lot of people throw it away
like I said I don't cuz that's meat
right there I'm gonna remove the legs
the meat and the body is a little softer
you don't need the crab cracker for this
part at all it's super soft you
literally just open it up and just feel
the meat off just make a little pile and
get some butter okay and then it's empty
I mean you don't want to have any meat
in there because even if you do like
this
juicy crabmeat are you ready for the big
guy alright so this one we are gonna
definitely crack at the joint okay so
you do that you crack it you want to
sort of take the cartilage out and then
when you open just this part doesn't
often come out like a perfect piece of
meat people get together and eat crab
and they have a beer and they're talking
your hands are dirty you feel like you
want to kind of hang out whenever I eat
crabs here at my store I actually eat
them right here so that I can talk to
everybody
fefe came up to me and said that she
wanted to open a crab restaurant and we
both were ready to do something
different I call her in the middle of
the night
are you serious do you really want to do
this she's like absolutely six months
later we opened up the Crab Shack to
hear other women say I want to try
something and you guys inspire me I
can't believe you know at 40 with kids
and you know we literally just left our
careers which we were very successful in
we took the bet and said you know what
we're gonna bet ourselves we were
determined to work for ourselves and
build our crappy shack Empire and that's
what excites me about it to know that
our future is just in front of us and
we're about to go get it